porque con él vamos a hablar del peligro
de las rutas migratorias irregulares
para ingresar a eeuu como las mafias de
trata de personas se aprovechan de las
necesidades de los migrantes poniendo la
vida de ellos como la última prioridad
estos propósitos los 53 migrantes
encontrados muertos en un trailer por
las autoridades de la ciudad texana de
san antonio un portavoz del departamento
de seguridad nacional de eeuu informó
que ya hay tres detenidos que se cree
que forman parte de esta conspiración de
contrabando de migrantes por su parte
presidente joe biden expresó sus
condolencias y dijo que su gobierno va a
realizar una investigación exhaustiva es
que este camión fue encontrado en una
zona de poco tránsito cerca de una vía
de tren en el suroeste de san antonio
que queda a unos 250 kilómetros la
frontera entre eeuu y méxico o salvamos
entonces a nuestro primer invitado el
día pierre cupón coordinador regional
del proyecto o camino protegido pie
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
le pregunto primeramente
se enfrentan estas personas que quieren
ingresar a eeuu por estas rutas
irregulares
hola algunos días a raúl mucho gusto
si no de hecho me gustaría iniciar con
el hecho posible esos como bien
mencionaba a los 53
muertas personas muertas en ese trailer
no podemos evitar pensar también en lo
que ocurrió el año pasado en diciembre
de 2021 también en tuxtla donde hubieron
55 muertos también en tamaulipas donde
encontramos 19 cuerpos
calcifica castigados entonces estamos
frente a una tendencia no estamos viendo
cada vez más esos acontecimientos
fatales y sobre todo mencionar que no se
trata de casos particulares estos casos
pasan todos los días en las fronteras
nada más ayer otra vez se encontraron a
más de 100 donde los que viajaban en un
trailer en el norte de
de méxico entonces porque a estas
personas pues toman este riesgo por
varias varias razones por supuesto
también por buscar oportunidades de vida
y también para
huir de actos violentos de entornos
violentos que pueden encontrar en sus en
sus países yo creo que las personas que
viajan y son en la gran mayoría bastante
conscientes de los peligros que claro
que y que puede encontrar en él en el
camino hace nada más algunos meses
escuchaba a una adolescente mencionar el
hecho de que prefería tomar el riesgo de
viajar que de esperar en su pueblo a que
la violen y la y la maté entonces
qué está pasando estamos justamente
conociendo una inestabilidad regional
cada vez más fuerte por razones
medioambientales
desastres naturales la inestabilidad
política entonces las personas van a
seguir
mi gran descaro emigrando creo que
estamos frente a una crisis no
únicamente
regional pero también
global
entonces estamos frente a
hay muchísimas demandas de solicitud de
refugio lo cual también las
instituciones se encuentran
saturadas por lo cual en ese momento
dejamos de estar retenido en la frontera
sur de méxico
pues las personas empiezan a buscar vías
alternativas de emigrar de migrar hacia
el norte y ahí es donde se ponen en
contacto con que podrían ser pues guzmán
al mercado negro que podríamos llamar el
siglo llamados coyotes y también nos
cree exacto grupos de directivos o
bandas criminales que les facilitan
entre comillas este este camino por lo
como bien lo mencionabas lo acciona a
cabo se trata únicamente de un negocio y
para nada
precisamente pero ahí me quiero enfocar
en estas redes de tráfico de personas
cómo operan estas redes como estas
personas llegan a estos llamados coyotes
para que los crucen hacia la frontera
mexicana y ya luego estando en
territorio estadounidense como es el
proceso digamos de asilo porque también
estas personas llegan de alguna manera
engañadas pensando que este proceso de
asilo es fácil este rápido en eeuu
y que tienen una gran posibilidad de
realmente que le den un asilo político
pero tampoco les pintan el otro lado de
la moneda que es que los pueden deportar
también perfectamente a su país de
origen y pues todo este tránsito hacia
eeuu pues no habría valido la pena
sí
sí yo creo que las personas en su gran
mayoría si conocen los riesgos en los
cuales se enfrentan sin embargo es
también
favorecer la desesperación la
desesperación de las personas tenemos
que saber que por ejemplo
estamos
con semanas son meses de espera para
resolver un tránsito migratorio
y además tenemos que un poco quizás
cambiar nuestra manera de imaginar a
este digamos a este proceso de
inmigración en general es cierto que la
antigua visión es un poco el el hombre
que va a buscar el sueño americano no
ahora nos encontramos con muchísimas
familias con mujeres con niñas niños
adolescentes que entonces por esperar su
tránsito migratorio están pues sin
trabajo y sin remuneración sin ingresos
sin acceso a salud sin educación
entonces es una desesperación que hace
que las personas si toman contacto con
personas pues otros por supuesto en el
camino que les dice si yo te puedo
facilitar
a seguir porque básicamente nos podemos
encontrar con personas que se encuentran
que se encuentran muriéndose de hambre
que no pueden alimentar a sus niñas y
ahí es donde justamente empiezan todo
esos riesgos a raúl de qué hablar de que
pueden ser trata al reclutamiento porque
también eso puede ser
como
como si como están muy expuestas
porque son al fin a cabo son muy
vulnerables frente a este tipo de
propuesta por parte del coyote que
también como lo mencionaba pero a lo que
voy es que efectivamente
hay todo
una una economía alrededor también de la
migración y economía entre comillas
porque estamos hablando de asaltos de
extorsión el secuestro de trata humana
y también de dinero enfocado justamente
al transporte